Jeff the drunk you're on the air hey
[ __ ] puppet yeah white beard I'm gonna
turn your picture right now he needs you
to make the puppet authentic what is it
truly the last two days worth of calls
you won't know what his topics were Troy
his topic today was I've never seed the
hobo load that's what he was on the
whole to talk to you about and then
yesterday you wanted to sing A Christmas
Carol to you is that right Jeff you've
never seen home alone no it's
fascinating the [ __ ] are we supposed to
do that information yeah what is your
point okay okay bye guys no no don't say
goodbye
ever what was your psyche what was your
point what now I'm not happy I'm asking
now I'm talking to you and you want
nothing [ __ ] give me eyes thank you
Jeff
Chad let me talk hello he picks it up he
puts the handset down when you talk and
then Jeff here's the deal you call in
because you want to make the statement
you've never seen the movie home alone
all right I'm going with you I say I say
to you okay so now I'm trying to talk to
you about it I'm trying not if I can go
with that I wonder what Jeff I'm going
with it tell me about this you say you
never saw the movie home alone okay what
about that how does that make you feel
we just [ __ ] thought right there's no
Club ID now now home alone
alright let me work with you on this
maybe you're onto something now home
alone we can find that Precure you that
I never saw home alone and ironically
I'm home alone all the time
now you talked at the point well let me
tell people a story about you I know
Christmas movies are important to you
when your mother was alive
rest in peace yes the two of you used to
sit in your trailer you would watch
Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer the
cartoon every year are there other
Christmas movies perhaps like the Grinch
that you have not seen maybe we can work
with that
maybe they said there's an interesting
pattern you know every [ __ ] year
alright so we've narrowed it down a
secret so what we what we figured out
now today and this is interesting Jeff
you're right out of all the Christmas
movies you've pretty much seen all the
major ones but not home alone and home
alone was released around 1990 which
would make it almost 30 years that
you've had the opportunity every
Christmas - what yeah isn't this
something tomorrow wow you're right this
is interesting
oh did you see screwed classy one year
how systems you're right about that yes
you are now I would imagine you've seen
Miracle on 34th Street I would imagine
it was like an white [ __ ] without elf
do you watch myself no alright well you
don't let you're right this has been
amazing it only took four people to make
it interesting
right oh my god he started this premise
a and it really isn't an interesting
premise I just had a thought no thought
no no
there's nothing behind the thought
we're aware yeah no we know there's
nothing behind there's a new thing he
does with his voice now yeah like when
he'll talk it'll take like a breath in
but there's like a little bit of word
that he does at the same time so it
almost sounds like a record playing
backwards like it'll go there so we can
build up yeah it's like on Led Zeppelin
to where like there's like a preamble
you know it's about doing so you know
what I noticed virtually all right there
is not another comic in the world that
says I'm a comedian as much as Julie as
well affect his daughter's first words
were I'm the comedian so you're saying
Jeff that delivers like that that surely
it has to remind people that he's a
comedian wait yeah but he says it so
often says tortas first words known I
think that I got it
is this a roast yeah do you want to
roast him back at all or life's pretty
much done that how about that all right
Jeff thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you